llega nuestra revista de prensa en esta
mañana de directo América de la mano de
Marta Moya Marta Un saludo para usted
Buenos días Buenos días Ángela vamos a
comenzar hoy con nuestros temas más
duros en el noticiero Ucrania tras el
anuncio de las tropas rusas en la
provincia de jerson la prensa
internacional reporta algunos de los que
han sido los momentos clave en esta
región estratégica del Sur del país que
podría pasar de ser la Gran Victoria de
Putin a la gran derrota vamos a empezar
con el repaso que hace al jazeera si
Ángela Buenos días vamos a empezar con
una cronología que hace al jazeera de
estos momentos clave que han sucedido en
la región de jerson a lo largo de estos
meses no desde el 24 de febrero hasta la
actualidad concretamente empezamos en el
24 de febrero en esta en esta región del
sur de Ucrania estratégica porque une
también con la Península de crimea
cuando el 24 de febrero entraron los
primeros vehículos blindados después muy
pocos días después el de marzo las
autoridades rusas reportaron tener el
control total de la ciudad de jerson
unos días más tarde el 15 de marzo
reclamaron tener el control total de la
región en el mes de mayo un poquito más
adelante Putin ofreció a los ciudadanos
de esa región visas bueno por la vía
rápida para la ciudadanía rusa de estas
personas en el mes de julio Ucrania
pidió a los civiles que evacuarán la
zona porque iba a empezar esa
contraofensiva un poquito más tarde en
septiembre las fuerzas de kiev
reclamaron haber conseguido 500
kilómetros cuadrados en la región de
gerson y esto supuso que el kremlin
impulsará estos referendos de anexión
entre el 23 y el 27 de septiembre por
supuesto después tres días más tarde con
los referendos aprobados Putin firmó los
decretos de anexión y pocos días después
y esto ya es un poco la antesala del
presente Ucrania empezó a recuperar
aldeas en las orillas del ni pro y
empezó estos avances no que ha motivado
que entre el 4 y el 7 de noviembre Putin
primero diera luz verde para que
salieran los civiles y ayer se consumará
La retirada de las tropas rusas y
estamos a la espera de ver qué es lo
siguiente que va a suceder porque no hay
confianza con este movimiento de las
tropas rusas también hay Relatos en el
Moscú Times si Ángela y el mosquito se
hace una especie de análisis que dice
show de propaganda Rusia lucha por
integrar las regiones ucranianas
anexadas según citan analistas a este
medio independiente ruso Aunque Rusia
quiere reclamar estas regiones como
propias y así lo hizo tras los
referendos de anexión en la práctica la
administración no está del todo
instalada en esta regiones recordemos do
nietz lugans zaporiya Y jerson dice
Bueno que aunque Rusia ha impulsado esta
este relato ni la administración
económica ni la política están presentes
en las regiones según reportan las webs
de estas administraciones prorusas en
las regiones ucranianas anexadas por
Rusia solo 10 funcionarios operan en
este territorio en zaporiya Y en donde
antes de la guerra vivían 2,5 millones
de personas claro este es una guerra de
armas pero también de retórica y de este
ocupamos este lugar y esto ahora es
nuestro Pero bueno la gente la gente
Marta vamos ahora con bloomberg
bloomberg reporta citando al jefe del
Estado Mayor de Estados Unidos que al
menos 100.000 tropas rusas han perdido
la vida o han quedado heridas en la
guerra en Ucrania Pues según Estados
Unidos no también reporta el jefe del
Estado Mayor de la defensa mcmilley que
Las bajas en el bando ucraniano serían
más o menos semejantes son las cifras
más precisas quedan desde Estados Unidos
desde el inicio de la invasión y además
citando al funcionario estadounidense
dice que debería existir de
negociaciones entre Rusia y Ucrania
porque por la vía militar ninguno de los
dos podrá reclamar la victoria entre
tanto varios medios de comunicación
llevan hoy en sus portadas el costo que
podría traer para que fue una victoria
republicana en las elecciones de medio
término como abordan este tema en
Spotify y este medio ruso dice que
Ucrania no ve con buenos ojos una
hipotética victoria republicana en
Estados Unidos no hay un temor de que el
partido republicano pueda o bloquear o
ralentizar estas ayudas sobre todo
económicas y militares que ha venido
desembolsando Washington a Ucrania en
los últimos meses cita a la ex Vice
primer ministra de Ucrania a una
entrevista que dio a político en la que
dice textualmente dependemos seriamente
no solo del apoyo estadounidense sino
también de su liderazgo en términos de
mantener el esfuerzo común de otras
naciones dice que además este artículo
del sputnik que en Octubre la el líder
de La minoría en la cámara de
representantes de Estados
dijo que a lo mejor estaría bien
repensar Un poco esta ayuda que se está
dando sobre todo viendo las condiciones
económicas que está sufriendo en estos
momentos Estados Unidos Mientras tanto
vaiden se ha esforzado por decir que
todo está bien y que van a seguir
ayudando a Ucrania no nos queda casi
tiempo rápidamente que dice el orden
mundial el orden mundial hace un
análisis de Alba Leiva en el que dice
todo lo que se juega Ucrania las miterms
dice bueno que este apoyo a Ucrania que
se podría ralentizar si los republicanos
ganan el congreso estadounidense podría
dar alas a Rusia si ve una desunión
entre Washington y los países de la otan
y Ucrania y la Unión Europea Perdón que
podrían verse bueno condicionadas por
esta ralentización del apoyo a Ucrania y
un resumen ultrarrápido del artículo del
Time que presenta alguno de estos
candidatos estadounidenses que han hecho
historia en las elecciones de medio
término sí hace un repaso de algunos
todavía no todos porque todavía no
tenemos resultados definitivos pero por
ejemplo
Morán heley que se es la primera
gobernadora abiertamente lesbiana en
Massachusetts Maxwell Frost que es el
primer demócrata de la generación Z que
ganó un escaño para la cámara en Florida
Robert García primer inmigrante de la
comunidad lgtbq que ganó un escaño en la
cámara por California Massachusetts
estará gobernado por primera vez por dos
mujeres Arkansas por dos mujeres en este
caso republicanas y Maryland que tiene
al primer gobernador negro y a la
primera vicegobernadora que es de origen
asiático perfiles que podrían consultar
más a profundidad en este artículo
gracias a ustedes Marta Le deseo que
tenga un feliz día gracias muy bien